je suis ami vient de présenter ces deux
nouveaux smartphones pour l'année 2023
je suis omi 13 sur 13 pro de smartphones
avec des design légèrement différents le
Xiaomi 13 a un écran plat tandis que le
Xiaomi 13 pro un écran incurvé alors
j'aime beaucoup le design qui est fait
le travail au niveau du dos notamment au
niveau du bloc photo et d'ailleurs ce
qu'on voit ce qui est génial c'est le
partenariat avec Leica qu'on a vu
arriver avec le Xiaomi 12 insultes
d'ailleurs j'en ai déjà parlé sur
Youtube on va aller très loin au niveau
de la photo avec notamment un capteur de
1 pouce sur le Xiaomi 13 pro on a des
optiques Leica on a deux modes
colorimétriques Leica on peut venir
filmer je t’en 4K 10 bits log faire des
photos également en haut des bits
calibré pour Adobe beaucoup de
performances avec le nouveau c'est un
dragon 8 Jane 2 en terme de technologie
c'est aussi dingue avec de la RAM en
lpdr 5x du stockage en ufs 4.0 bref sont
des smartphones qui ont tout pour
déchirer en 2023 on en reparle très
bientôt en attendant dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires